[موسيقى]
الحرب بدات للتو ولن تنتهي الا باعاده
الحق لاصحابه وخلاف بين المانيا وبولندا
والسبب روسيا واحشاء البحر الاسود تشهد
ساحه معارك طاحنه اذا انقطع دعمكم فهذا
انتحار لاوروبا وكمين روسي ينهي كتيبه
اوكرانيه خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه روسيا
تعرن قبول التفاوض والجنوح للسلام
والرئاسه الاوكرانيه تطلب النجده العاجله
من امريكا بعد كسر دفاعاتها الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقتحم جني مجددا والمقاومه ترد
بقوه والاليات الاسرائيليه تشتعل
الحرب تنتقل الى احشاء المحيطات
قوات موسكو تتقدم في البر ومقاتلاتها
تسيطر على الجو الاوكراني اذا ما الذي
تبقى نعم هو ما تفكر انها معارك البحار
والمحيطات وهنا تندلع معركه البحر الاسود
لتتلطم امواج العاتيه وتشتعل حساباته
الكثيره والمعقده والفائز من يضحك اخيرا
ويسيطر على هذا البحر الاستراتيجي فامسك
الرئيس الاوكراني بالميكروفون في اوديسا
واطلق كلمات اراد ان يسمعها نظيره الروسي
بوتين وفي جمله مكرره روسيا لن تسيطر على
البحر الاسود روسيا لن تسيطر على البحر
الاسود وذهب سيلنسكي ابعد من ذلك ليحذر
موسكو من مغبه الاقتراب من شواطئ شبه
جزيره القرم لكن
تسيطر على معظم البحر الاسود فهيله من
تهديد عاطر ينزل
ضيف انه لا يمكن تخيل اوكرانيا من دون شبه
جزيره القرم وان الحرب لن تنتهي الا باست
من القبضه الروسيه وذلك في مقابله مع شبكه
يبدو ان زالنسكي في احلام اليقظه ونسي انه
قد فقد اربع مقاطعات اخرى بعيدا عن القرن
فعن اي استعاده يتحدث واما رئيس مكتب
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
فعاد الى التوسل للحصول على مقاتلات اف 16
زعما هذه المره ان بطء وطيره هجوم قوتك
يعود الى تمتع روسيا بميزه الجو وهنا
طلبات الاوكراني لا تتوقف رغم فشل قواتهم
على الارض ولكن هذه المره تعود كييف
لطلبات الحربيه حيث قال اليكسينج بابا
قائد القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه ان تتطلع
لتلقي سفن حربيه تتمتع بقدرات وامكانات
تقنيه عاليه من شركائها الغربيين مهلا
مهلا مهلا بقي طلب اوكراني اخر حيث قال
وزير الخارجيه
قبل القمه المرتقبه لحلف شمال الاطلس
النيتو ان عدم قبول عضويه اوكرانيا في
الخلف بعد انتهاء الغزو الروسي سيكون
بمثابه انتحار لاوروبا لان الطريقه
الوحيده لاغلاق الباب امام العدوان الروسي
على اوروبا والفضاء الاوروبي الاطلسي ككل
هو ضم اوكرانيا للحلف وفق تعبيره وهنا
ننتقل الى الحرب والمعارك الدائره على
الارض حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تحيد نحو 500 وتسعين عسكريا اوكرانيا على
محاور القتال وتدمير خمسه مستودعات
للذخيره ومقاتله سو سبعه وعشرين اوكرانيه
وهو المصدر يتحدث امامكم فنحن لا نؤكد
الارقام ولا ننفها كالعاده بينما اعلن
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي عن محباط
محاوله اغتيال رئيس شبه جزيره القرم
الموالي لروسيا سيرغي اكسيون واتهم الامن
المخابرات الاوكرانيه بالوقوف وراء محاوله
الاغتيال اما القتال فارتفعت حدته مجددا
لتعترف اوكرانيا بتقدم القوات الروسيه على
اربعه محاور في الدنيا في مقاله نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني فان قوات بلادها
تقاتل بضراوه وحققت نجاحا في باخموت وفي
جنوب البلاد لننتقل الى حرب الدبابات حيث
قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سركيشي ان القوات
الروسيه دمرت جميع الدبابات
التي سلمت بولندا والبرتغال الى كييف ويا
فرحه ما تمته لم تكد تكمل فرحتها
بالدبابات الغربيه حتى ابتلعتها قوات
موسكو لتاتي الاغاثه من وزير الدفاع
الالماني بوريس بيستوريوس والذي قال ان
العشرات من دبابات تصل الى اوكرانيا
الاسابيع المقبله من المانيا والدنمارك
لكن عن الدبابات تتحدث يا هذا فالسلطات
الالمانيه والفولنديه قد فشلت في التوصل
الى اتفاق لانشاء مركز اصلاح لدبابات
وغيرها من المعدات لفائده القوات
الاوكرانيه وذلك لان برلين وورزو تتجادلان
بشكل متواصل حول تفاصيل المشروع المشترك
بحسب صحيفه ومن جهه اخرى حذر نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي لمترميدف من ان مواجهه
موسكو مع الغرب ستستمر عقودا وان صراعها
مع اوكرانيا قد يصبح دائما وذكر ان الحرب
النوويه محتمله جدا لكن من غير المرجح ان
تسفر عن اي منتصر ما يرى محللون غربيون ان
الحديث عن المواجهه النوويه يعكس بعض
الافكار التي تتردد على اعلى مستوى في
الكرمنين اي انها احدى خيارات موسكو
لمواجهه الغرب حقا بينما عدم تفيديب هنا
ان روسيا مستعده لبحث التسويات المعقوله
للخروج من الازمه الدوليه الحاليه بشرط
اخذ مصالحها في الاعتبار فهل يقبل الغرب
ويمسكون بهذه اليد الروسيه الممدوده
للسلام الامر متروك لهم وهنا خرجت النتيجه
نهائيه للحرب يعلنها رئيس اللجنه العسكريه
للنيت والادمر الروبور بان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه متضرره لكنها لم تهزم باي حال من
الاحوال في الحرب في اوكرانيا مؤكدا انه
لا ينبغي ابدا التقليل من شان روسيا
وقدرتها على التعافي
محرقه جنين قوات الكيان تشتعل غضبا الجيش
يتقدم باكثر من 2000 جندي اسرائيلي
ليشاركوا في العمليه العسكريه والهدف هو
جنين ومخيمها ليعلنها جيش الكيان بان هذه
العمليه ستستمر يومين بهدف ازاله التهديد
من المنطقه هما كذا يقولون ونحن امام احدى
اكبر العمليات بالضفه الغربيه منذ 20 عاما
يا اصدقاء حيث اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال جنين
ومخيمها بالمدرعات والجنود واسراب من
الطائرات المسيره لتعلنها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وعلى لسان عرين الاسود سنريكم
ارضا محروقه واضافت ان المقاومه في كل
الساحات لن تسمح للعدو بالتوغل على اهل
جنين او الاستفراد بهم هناك تمكنت
المقاومه من اعطاب عدد من الاليات
الاسرائيليه واسقاط مسيرتين في معلمه
الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاده تسعه فلسطينيين
واصابه نحو 50 اخرين جراء هذا الاقتحام
لتطالب فلسطين بعقد اجتماع عاجل لمجلس
الجامعه العربيه لبحث مواجهه العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه على جنين ومخيمها
[موسيقى]